Cody Sanchez is the founder of
contrarian thinking the following
conversation was recorded at a live
event called lyceum Miami which my team
and I hosted on March 4th at the Miami
Beach Convention Center here is my
conversation with Cody Sanchez I think
the first place to start
are we headed towards a recession do we
think that things are going to get worse
than they currently are or is that just
a mainstream talking point to scare
people and actually folks should just
operate as they have yeah it's a great
question I also want to start by just
saying hysterical that I'm coming after
a presidential candidate like no
pressure at all so when you guys see him
on CNBC next and I'm on YouTube there's
just like a slight deviance YouTube may
be bigger than CNBC that's right you
tell them the vet
um so okay uh recession do I think we're
coming into one here's the truth
uh nobody knows nobody literally knows
there's this joke in economics which
only nerds think is funny which is that
how do you know an economist has a sense
of humor he uses decimal points and so
in economics we basically know a couple
things that we humans love to predict
things loudly largely on CNBC get them
wrong get a book deal done and then
maybe a movie afterwards and so I think
the truth of the matter is nobody knows
if we're coming into a recession and I
actually think that's the wrong question
it's a totally wrong question great
great start yeah it actually you guys
funny story uh pomp one of the reasons I
definitely wanted to be here today is
when I used to have like zero followers
on the internet I was pretty much brand
new uh now we got a couple million of
you helians out there following us
um he was one of the first guys who gave
me a platform and I will always be
grateful of that and I'm sure you guys
are grateful he put this together so I
think he needs a little bit of this
how many people do this just it's a big
big thing putting together events so I
think that's super cool
um the right question is actually this
are you prepared for a moment in history
in which things go on sale to a level
that they've never been on sale during
the time you had cash that's the right
question are you ready is it tomorrow I
don't know is it next year I don't know
I do know one thing nothing goes like
this forever the pendulum always swings
and so my question to people is are you
ready and most people's answer is no and
they panic and they sell or they stay
out of the market and they miss and then
what happens the rich get richer and the
rest of us we pay for it and so I think
the question you all should be asking
yourselves today is do I have the
knowledge I need to put whatever money
skills and unfair advantages I have to
work because at some point will go
on sale and will I actually be able to
capitalize on it that's the right
question I do think it happens in the
next two years I don't know when
when you think about the current
economic environment
um Tech was very hot for two years three
years when we were had loose monetary
policy now as we get into this
tightening cycle and deeper and deeper
into it uh we have seen in the public
markets the value uh investment thesis
has proven out we saw you know Berkshire
Hathaway hit all-time highs kind of all
of those stocks that are really really
focused on cash flow are working in the
public markets you're doing this in the
private markets is there a very similar
result that you're seeing of what the
public market investors are seeing in
the private Market or there's some
differences because the capital
structures or something else yeah
um it's always friction what makes the
difference between somebody who is like
you who has created the life that you
have and most people the difference is
what you've done is pretty hard and so
because there's friction to it there's
less people that play in the arena the
same thing is true in private markets
think about what happened in sorry guys
crypto and also Tech rip is is Kathy
Wood in the room still because that
would make this awkward but uh Tech got
murdered and the reason why Tech and
crypto got murdered is because you could
take your phone you could click a button
and you could have an adrenaline rush
that allowed you to purchase something
immediately and feel like you were smart
and making money
now in the private markets the reason
why I love buying these boring
businesses is because I'm actually much
less smart Than A Cafe what is she's got
degrees up to here but it's a lot harder
to go and buy a business that's not on
any listing that you can't have a bunch
of Robin hooders on there buying at the
same point so my point to this is there
probably is never going to be a time
where my laundromats and car washes are
at 20x they're forward-looking earnings
like that's just not going to happen
because not everybody can go out there
and buy them the friction is real and so
um our private markets slightly inflated
I think so but will they ever get to a
degree where you can have a 55 percent
downturn in one year and have to recoup
double the amount the next year like
Tech I I don't think that's very likely
until there's a way that you can buy
with a button and that's why I don't
like to play in games where I have to be
the smartest one in the realm I just
don't play in those games because I'm
never going to be the smartest one in
the room I'm never going to beat a Kathy
Wood head ahead on looking at individual
stock analysis but I might beat somebody
like a Kathy Wood because I don't play
her game I play a game that people think
is boring that people think is beneath
them they will never get me on CNBC
because I'll never invest in the next
Tesla I'm going to invest in The Lex Car
Wash and that's going to cash flow me
like a bond every single month and I'm
gonna be happy as a clam hanging out on
South Beach so you have two different
businesses one is what I consider more
of like an asset management acquisition
holding company style and then the other
is a business where there's a lot of
content and kind of more product based
let's start with maybe the contrarian
thinking business itself like how should
we think about that and I want to use
you as the example of somebody who
thinks about private markets cash flow
uh being prepared for economic downturns
right you can say a lot of stuff like
what are you doing right and so like how
do you think about the business that you
operate and then we'll talk about the
Acquisitions yes three words skin in the
game uh show me where you put your money
instead of tell me where you put your
money completely agree so I mean we have
portfolio of 20-ish businesses that do
about 50 million in Revenue in the
boring business side and I say that
because most of us don't have access to
this private Equity world where the
wealthiest people play this they own
more than any other subset of humanity
across not just the us but the globe
it's not the public market investors
that end up becoming the richest people
in the world in fact if you look at the
Forbes 100 list of the Forbes 100 nobody
got on that list from Pure passive stock
market investing not one and somebody
might say well what about Carl Icahn
he's an activist investor and he does
Acquisitions that are behind the scenes
with secondary shares so there is this
fake news fallacy that is sold to us
every single day
on places like CNBC where they try to
make us think that because Kramer hits a
gavel we should buy X or Y or Z and it's
totally wrong so my money goes into
exactly what I'm telling you guys I buy
these little boring businesses and then
something started to happen to me in
2020. I realized after you did
um that there's a network effect that's
never happened before Naval ravacott
talks about it four levels of Leverage
originally we had employment right we
had labor labor was our first type of
Leverage all the way back to when that
was slaves to today as employees the
second type was capital capital was when
the Rothschilds and the world's
billionaires back then were created was
because of the Advent of the banking
system they had access to more Capital
than could fit in their pockets the
third leverage event was code so that
was when we saw Bill Gates and Elon Musk
and all of these guys start to have
access to code which allowed them to
have unfair leverage the number one type
of Leverage today what are you guys
think yes
audience it's audience it's not
necessarily social but it's the fact
that we are at a war for eyeballs and so
why wouldn't I build a media Empire
around this boring business Empire that
will never be worth 20 exits
forward-looking earnings but my media
business talking about it could be so we
have a practice we talk about it
contrarian thinking called document
instead of create so instead of us just
going out there and coming up with crazy
ideas all the time I'm just like well
I'm going to speak to my friend pomp
events today I'm going to document this
process I'm going to go buy a laundromat
oh that deal fell through I'm going
to document that process that
documentation nobody used to care about
in 2020 I thought people would think it
was so boring laundromats car washes I
want to be an astronaut turns out people
care about this and you can add this
leverage to whatever it is you're doing
so I think today
one what are you going to do if a
recession hits two are you in the war
for eyeballs because if you're not in
the war you're fighting it and you don't
even know it
when you think about the businesses that
you do own let's go through maybe a deal
that blew away your expectations and
then a deal that did not meet
expectations and you're like damn we
shouldn't have done that deal yeah uh
well one of the deals I talk about
um that was a terrible deal that I did I
remember it was the first deal I lost
50k at and maybe that doesn't seem like
that much money but back in the day that
was a lot for me that was like my first
deal I thought I really knew what I was
doing and there's three things I did
wrong one uh this deal I did with a
friend I did with a buddy and anytime
you do a deal with a buddy you have to
set expectations just like you're
getting married you have to start with
the end in mind AKA a prenup for
marriage or what's called a partnership
agreement in investing the second thing
that I did wrong in that deal is I
invested in the area that I had no
unfair Advantage it was a food company
and I don't know about you guys but food
is complicated it spoils constantly and
I knew nothing about it so I thought hey
first time investor in an area I know
nothing about seems like a great idea
turns out it's not and then the third
thing I did wrong in that deal is I
didn't set expectations really clearly
on what I wanted out of the deal so in
our world this is called a term sheet so
basically like I get my money back in
this amount of time you do this if you
don't do this I have this happen most
people invest their money based on hopes
and prayers and not based on realities
and contracts the latter is better so
that was the worst deal I've ever done
now some of the best deals I've ever
done and I'm gonna I'm gonna use deals
that are accessible because how many
people in here have ever invested in a
private Market deal before raise your
hand
okay we've got a few how many people
have done a deal over a hundred thousand
in private markets before okay not very
many perfect
let me tell you something you can buy
businesses and invest in the private
markets in a way you could never do in
the stock markets guess how much money
you need to do a private deal
zero dollars
you need zero dollars to do a private
deal now is that always gonna happen no
but can that happen yes because of
things like seller financing and
creative financing so my favorite deals
are little deals like ones you guys
could do today I bought a business not
too long ago called approachment.com I
bought it for sixty thousand dollars the
business but zero dollars up front sixty
thousand dollars over the course of the
year the business was doing like seventy
five thousand dollars in Revenue I'm
sorry in profit that year why would that
idiot sell me a business for sixty
thousand students seventy five thousand
dollars that year it's usually what
people say because he's 65 it was one of
many of his businesses he was ready to
retire nobody else wanted to buy it so I
said no you're welcome I'll buy it for
this amount of money and I'll give you
some of the upside I'll give you five
percent that business will now do three
hundred thousand dollars this year and
it is a boring business we run from our
phone with off uh outsourced talent and
a little bit of tech behind it those
deals are all around you the problem is
Wall Street likes to buy them Main
Street doesn't get to know about him
when you start to look at some of these
businesses you've already done the deal
right and I think you talk a lot about
doing the deal yeah what are you doing
to optimize to grow to kind of integrate
it and how much of on the back end are
you actually leveraging the businesses
for each other so you have a car wash uh
business and then oh we actually have a
business that cleans car washes and so
now we have a customer in within the
portfolio or are you just allowing these
to operate individually and you're not
really trying to find any sort of
um you know benefits by cross promoting
them to each other
there's levels to the game right
um and if I'm really honest I'm like uh
if there's 10 levels I'm a level three
operator I really am not that I don't
have that much attention to detail I
don't love the operations inside of a
business I don't really want to spend a
bunch of time twisting knobs what I like
to do is I'm a deal junkie I love doing
the deal I love executing the deal I
love putting somebody else in it and
then I'm like I want to do the next deal
and so
um the level 10 player would basically
say I'm going to buy a bunch of
businesses like Amazon does and then
they would integrate those businesses
fully into what they do and they would
get a 10x return for every 1X business
that they buy because they get rid of
all the back office people they add all
their Systems and Technology
turns out I'm not Jeff Bezos so
I don't do it that way all that I do and
I'm honest about this because I want
more people to buy small businesses
because if you don't buy them they just
go away or the big guys buy them and I
don't know about you but I don't need
more Walmarts uh on the street corner or
Starbucks I'd prefer more mom and pop
pop stores so uh I just put these
businesses in a portfolio I have a
couple people at top that review and
manage all of them but I really don't do
much on the back end to integrate them
they're like little bonds and those
bonds send me a coupon every single
month or every single quarter but
they're out there doing their own thing
just like you guys probably have a bunch
of stocks in your portfolio and you're
not like well how is Apple working
together with Amazon in conjunction with
whatever you're like nah I got a 15
dividend awesome
so I want to make sure I read this
correctly because it is uh wow uh
Financial Fridays oh yeah explain what
this is
um one of my favorite mentors told me
that money is a cruel mistress and if
you don't pay attention to her she'll
leave you
and I say that again money is a cruel
mistress and if you don't pay attention
to her she will leave you
and I think that's very true and yet we
kind of treat her like something we're a
little afraid to look at like oh
what did my bank account do today oh I
don't know about that Robin Hood account
and so I learned from this Mentor his
name was David Osborne we were going on
a walk and I thought I was gonna I was
gonna get the advice from this guy who's
worth 100 million bucks back then to me
that sounded like a bajillion dollars so
I'm like David what does it take
whatever and instead like most really
wealthy people do he flipped it on me
then he asked me a bunch of questions he
said what are you worth exactly and I
was excuse me and he was like no no uh
exact dollar amount I'm like well I
don't know carry the one he's like
you're never going to be rich I was like
okay cool this is going well and um and
then he's like you'll never be rich if
you don't know where your money is and
if you don't pay attention to it so I
listened and I said okay like what
exactly does that mean that sounds a
little theoretical like I I do like
money I want more of it and he said uh
every single week he has a time with the
members of his team because he has a lot
of them where they sit down and they
look at the finances so I started doing
this I didn't have that much money at
the time I was still working in finance
and so every Friday for every single one
of my businesses I do something very
easy
let's say you guys have a mint account
or your personal finances I basically
look at my bank account I see week over
week what happened and the difference
between the two and then as you get more
complex right now for every single
business I have a little scorecard and
the scorecard goes red yellow green is
it going to hit the numbers that I think
it's supposed to hit this week if not a
double click on that bad boy and I try
to figure out why and I do that every
Friday and the reason why is because
money is a mistress and she will leave
you
there's a lot of people in the audience
who have side hustles small businesses
some people have Tech startups but for
the people who aren't necessarily
sitting in a room with three engineers
and they can build and do whatever they
want from a technology standpoint what
are some of your favorite tools to help
run these small businesses whether it's
from kind of a holding company structure
or it's somebody who just have one
business I'm just focused on growing
this business how can they use
technology to actually grow those
businesses yeah it's a great question I
would start with a question back and
that question is where in your business
does it feel hard like where in your
business do you feel stuck where in your
business do you have a bunch of people
and managing those people is annoying
because where your pain is is where your
potential profit is stuck and so in my
business I our saying is based off a
book that I can't remember the guy's
name uh is is there's a book called who
not how and so I first when I have a
pain point I go who can solve this for
me and then I ask that person when they
start delving into it how can Tech solve
this for you we did a little challenge
at my company where I actually haven't
given the results yet I probably need to
do that for them I gave a thousand
dollars to whoever could figure out the
best way for AI to replace something in
the company and we're going to run this
on a quarterly basis and so I
continuously say to the team I'm going
to reward you for replacing yourself
because there's never a shortage of work
but there's always a shortage of
curiosity to acceleration and I find
owners are really good at saying God I
don't want to spend any more money on
humans doing XYZ task employees are not
good at that they're going to hammer
their head against the wall until you
ask them oh wait a second you are
actually responding to every single DM
on Instagram when there are 372
different software tools to do it and oh
in fact not only that there's these chat
tools that can do it for 29 a month but
I pay you a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars a year last comment on that you
can run an analysis which I like to do
and my team who's here will probably
have heard me say this which says like
how much do you make that's beneath your
pay grade and so I don't want them to
get entitled about it but I want every
single human going if I make a hundred
thousand dollars a year that's I don't
know what the real annual rate hourly
rate is but that's 35 dollars an hour
and so every time I have a task that
could be cheap more cheaply done than 35
an hour I want them figuring out how to
do that and when you do that you create
owners because owners think to delegate
and employees think to do and that's the
difference between the two why I won't
give you an individual Tech Tool is
because I can see this audience already
you guys do a lot of different things if
I give you one or two Tech tools you're
gonna leave here feeling like I got a
tactic I'm gonna do my to-do list
checking I'm gonna go use it and it's
not going to be applicable what will
change your life are not tactics but the
right questions
when you think about the questions you
ask yourself every day what are they
one should I actually be doing this
thing that I'm doing right now is this
one item I'm working on right now a
three standard deviation event maker for
me or not a three standard deviation
event means you have a bell curve like
this we all remember it you know the
teacher used to goes yep C for you right
so you have ABC I want three standard
deviation events which means that they
are three groupings away from the norm I
want the things that are going to have
an unfair advantage on my business if I
spend all day responding to text
messages and emails I'm never going to
have that Kathy Wood money I don't know
she was here earlier so she's on the top
of my mind poor Kathy
um so anyway I'm never going to have
that kind of cash because I'm spending
all my time on low level activities and
so the most important question you can
ask yourself is like should you actually
be doing this thing right in front of
you or are you suffering from the worst
disease you could get which is recency
bias because it just came in I am going
to do it it's why if you're friends with
me and in this audience you know I don't
respond to text messages right away I
don't respond to emails I've lost
friends because of that I think sending
a voice note is akin to assault I hate
voice notes do you like those
things I I don't send voice notes no
thank you they're awful one of my my one
of my neighbors actually would send them
to me and I kept pretending uh like I
wasn't getting them I was like oh whoops
it's not working can't can't answer and
finally he called me and he's like oh
you want me to walk you through it I go
buddy
you sending me a voice note
is the worst part of my day and um and
he said why and I said because they're
really annoying like I could read it in
two seconds now I have to listen to
three minutes how are you what's going
on how are the kids I'm really nice by
the way
um and anyway and then he said no
they're really helpful and I said for
you the sender not me the receiver and
so if you want to have an outsized life
if you want to have a life that's a
little bit different than everybody
else's but you do the same thing
everybody else does the old adage is
true you will never have an outsized
life if you allow other people
to steal your time and so I try to live
by that what does your daily schedule
look like
similarities and then a lot of deviation
I always like that quote I do this 60 of
the time every time
um so I think uh we have a couple things
so Financial Fridays I film on Thursdays
because now I do this content thing
um on Mondays and Wednesdays I take
phone calls
uh Tuesdays no phone calls and I'm
writing a book so I work on the book on
Tuesday
um at first when I was still an employee
back in the day uh I was in finance
everybody was working 70 hour weeks uh
nobody was ever uh offline you would
take phone calls whenever you got it and
I remember uh reading a book at the time
and realizing that my day was being
hijacked every single day was hijacked
by somebody else and that's why Bankers
have to work 70 hour weeks and I thought
what if I just instituted one thing
which is I will never take a phone call
before 10 in the morning ever like
pending somebody's dying if you're not
dying I'm not picking it up and uh and I
did that and I thought ah I'm gonna get
fired like no way I'm not gonna get
fired and what turns out is nobody
noticed I out produced everybody else
and that window of like you know seven
to ten became my most productive part of
the day so I still do that to this day
except now I bunched it back to 12 since
I worked for myself and I can now
when you're doing the calls or these
with uh prospective companies to buy are
they with partners are they with
companies that you already own how often
do you talk to the companies you already
own yeah good question I only talked to
the companies I own on Fridays I
typically try to do as few meetings as
possible I do think meetings are the
kiss of death except that you have to
have them and I've never found a way so
if anybody has one love to know to get
rid of all meetings in a business I
think that's really hard to do so on
Fridays I will meet with the portfolio
companies that I have but I'm I'm a
little bit of a crazy person about
meetings and so
um the meetings that we have now all of
them and our team here would tell you
this too they have an agenda that gets
sent out every single week
if you have issues that you want to talk
about if you have items you want to
cover you need to send you need to put
it in the agenda beforehand when we get
to the meeting then people can respond
and engage with the comments but you
needed to put it in beforehand and you
really probably should have read that
bad boy beforehand and that's because
the most precious commodity we have is
our time and we give it away all the
time it's the biggest mistake humans
make because we haven't figured out life
extension yet and so um I'm pretty crazy
about meetings then on Monday I have the
meetings in the one company that I run
every single day so I think my Mondays
are kind of miserable but I I like that
Mark twainism of if you're gonna eat a
frog eat in the morning and if you're
gonna eat two eat the big one first
oh thank you meeting clap I like that
never before ever have I gotten a clap
for my meeting agenda
um when you think of uh a team
especially in Good Times first bad times
how have you thought about where to find
Talent how to incentivize Talent when to
uh you know part ways with Talent like
that for most small businesses is the
business is like who are the people who
work here how have you thought about
those things
so hard
the most important skill you can acquire
in life if you want to have generational
what I call you level of money
is to bring other people along with you
because you simply cannot do it by
yourself
simultaneously I once um when I was
starting my very first business I went
to one of my mentors at Goldman and he
said he listened to my pitch I told him
what I was going to do and he said I
already know what your biggest problem
is going to be and I said okay great
tell me and he goes no I want you to
find it out for yourself and I was like
okay and so I put it in an envelope and
he dated it and he and he you know he
wrote inside he put an album he licked
it and he wrote on top of it so he'd
know that I couldn't open it he goes in
six months come to me when you have your
biggest problem and I'm going to tell
you what it's going to be so I came back
in six months I'm like problem is he's
like let me tell you and so he opens up
the envelope and on the piece of paper
is one word and it's people
the worst part about your business your
people the best part about your business
your people
and so um Choose Wisely uh if I told you
that I was an expert at this I'd be
lying in fact I don't think anybody has
this figured out and probably you've
guessed this just by listening to
anybody on stage we all really don't
know what we're doing everybody up here
is just sitting in a sack of skin
thinking I hope people don't figure this
out and at any moment a business is a
fast-moving train on a really wobbly
track and so
um I have some ideas on how to get great
people uh but I don't know that those
are the best ideas so I'll always give
you two and then you guys tell me what
you think the first idea for bringing
incredible people along with you and
finding them
is to uh build in public and so people
have made this a little bit more normal
now but in 2020 when I was in finance
and I said that I was going to start
actually telling people about what I do
my partners at my private Equity Firm I
mean they almost they almost they're
trying to figure out how to get me out
of the partnership agreement they were
like social media nightmare nobody can
know look what happened to Mitt Romney
and on the election you know pitchforks
are going to come out and I was like I
just don't think we can attract the best
talent if they don't know about us and
so I think the best thing that you can
do is get on social media in some way
shape or form and start building in
public in fact we were talking to vivex
team back stair uh backstage and he was
saying they're going to do an open
source Campaign which she's talked about
publicly so I don't think I'm giving
anything away why do you think he's
doing that do you think he's just like
this seems nice I want to do it for the
people he's like no this is because the
way to attract Talent today is to let
people see what you're doing naturally
we don't believe anything anymore as
humans because we've seen you know what
most politicians do we've seen what most
leaders do the only way people believe
you is by you actively showing them and
so that's the number one way to find
Talent the number two way I think to
find Talent is be incredible to the
people that are with you so that first
hire that you have even if they suck
make sure when you fire them you do it
in the right way that second hire that
you have even if they are your worst
employee that you've ever had make sure
that you're transparent and honest and
when I tell people to buy businesses
what do you think the number one reason
is that people want to leave a job
shout it out
the boss it's always the boss
the man
the problem is
what were the bosses at one point
they are somebody else's employee and so
it's kind of like this generational uh
employee abuse we passed down from the
time we were an employee to the time we
become a boss
and so what I would say is as you guys
go out there and buy businesses your
number one thing to pass on is like be a
better boss than your last one be
slightly better because people talk and
the world now one person talks they
press a tweet and everybody can hear you
how much of what you've been doing can
you automate so you talked about the
team you talked about uh your day and
kind of the time boxing and things like
that but is this eventually going to get
to the point where somebody can like
write you an email and you'll buy the
business off an email
um how repeatable is this if you already
have you know 24 25 companies
could you manage 200 300 30 what does
that look like
the answer is yes uh scale and
automation is completely doable at to a
level that I'm not sure I I see an end
inside I mean if you think about it
somebody Googles and looks it up you can
look up how many companies Amazon has
bought it's it's hundreds
um and so when I tell people I own 24
businesses they're like liar no you
don't I'm like you guys you've had the
Matrix covering your eyes for so long
you don't realize that all around you
the big boys don't grow organically they
grow through acquisition they just don't
want you to know because they hope you
stay in the nine to five cubicle the
rest of your life yelling at people on
Twitter that tell you they own multiple
businesses and so let me tell you how I
really feel about that huh
um so I think
the truth of the matter is if Bezos can
run as big of an organization as he did
with as many underlying companies in it
I don't see an end in sight now I'm not
I'm no Bezos but I think as Tech gets
better and better this becomes easier
and easier and think about it this way
like how many doors does the biggest
real estate company own how many uh
individual Apartments do property
managers run as we get better technology
for buying businesses it's all going to
be democratized both from technology and
access right now we're at this weird
part where if I told you guys hey let me
tell you what you can go buy a house
right now somebody else can give you
money to buy it and you can have
somebody else run it so you can cash
flow on it what do you say uh duh yeah
we've been doing that for decades thanks
Cody if I tell you that about buying
businesses what do people say that's
weird is that possible and so the same
thing is happening with businesses it
just hasn't been democratized yet
there's two questions that people sent
in I I don't let anyone ask any
questions because I didn't know what you
guys would all ask I'm joking
um but uh two questions that somebody
sent in one was uh you got your MBA uh
was it helpful and would you go get it
again
I gotten this question a lot like my
little like the little poster in me
from Twitter is like no you know
um uh that said
I like to think about it honestly like
if I had a child today you have a child
I don't know if anybody's gonna allow me
that but say I have one at one point
um would I want them to have some of the
experiences and opportunities I did when
I went to school what I want them to be
able to go to an MBA if I could do I
feel like there's an unfair access that
you get when you can put that at the end
of your name I think the answer is still
actually yes and all the people online
that are telling you like you don't need
a degree you don't need an MBA it's like
yeah but tiny asterisks and so the
asterisk says if you can get into a top
tier and by that I've been a very small
top tier level MBA it is an unfair cheat
code on the world because people would
assume you're a lot smarter than you
actually are and so I went to Georgetown
MBA and because of that people still
listen I mean I've done a few other
things and they'll be like Cody Sanchez
she went to Georgetown and I'm like yeah
I did and so um I think it's still a
cheat code
do I think if you have a hundred
thousand dollars right now you should
put it towards an MBA because it will
make you more money than buying a
business or getting in the game of
business no if you want to learn
business go do business I'm not a rocket
scientist but that seems to make sense
and so I think it's a huge disservice
that we have turned this this idea of a
masters of Business Administration as
some credential that puts you in a place
where you understand how to run a p l
where you understand what it feels like
when you can't pay your employees on
Friday because the business is not doing
so hot when you understand what it feels
like the first time you get sued that
you understand what it feels like to
have something go really viral and not
be able to keep up with growth your
teachers have never felt that they have
sat behind a desk trying to tell you the
theory of business as told by the
Socratic method that to me is like
trying to explain to somebody what sex
feels like by watching it on a Hallmark
movie
it doesn't work
last question is uh somebody asked they
have a full-time job they want to buy a
business should they pursue buying the
business and trying to run it while
keeping the full-time job or should they
jump obviously there's a lot of details
in there that probably matter but how do
you think about being able to run a
business and like being the actual
operator day to day versus buying it
trying to have another team run it maybe
you keep a full-time job yeah I'm Jekyll
and Hyde on this on one side
don't be the bad boss and don't be the
bad employee if you're going to say that
you are dedicating your life to a
Pursuit whether it's in a career where
you own the business or somebody else
does be a person of your word why
because the world's small and people
remember and so if you're going to buy a
small business and you work for somebody
else do it the right way the right way
is you don't steal your time from them
we have this theory that like the boss
sucks and whatever but remember that
will be you one day and I actually
believe that karma's a real in
business and so you are going to be like
that little child that says to their mom
well when I'm a parent I'm never going
to do that and then you have a kid and
you're like Mom so what happened today
was and you did the exact same thing and
so be really careful being a bad
employee because you think your employer
sucks get a new job take the risk get
your own ships to get in the game on the
other hand do I think that you should
quit your job right now where you're
making money in order to go take a huge
risk and in a business and potentially
bankrupt yourself or have to sleep on a
couch no I think the right way to do
this
is instead of a side hustle buy a
business that allows you enough money to
put an operator in and do it in
transparency with the business that
you're working with or get a job where
that's acceptable and then go and run
the next thing or take the big risk
I find in life life rewards you and the
universe rewards you for going all in
any time you teeter-toe the universe is
kind of like this is my woo-woo Austin
coming out actually the uh the universe
it kind of tests you and and your boss
is going to find out and then you're
going to panic this happened to me
before and then I panicked and I didn't
do the thing and I think I would have
had another zero which would be
substantial behind my name if I had said
okay fine I'm gonna actually go do the
thing right now so I think the universe
rewards risk done at the right time
where can we send people to find out
more about what you're doing or if they
want to follow along and learn across
social or right the emails that you guys
send out yeah uh I think Cody Sanchez on
Instagram if you guys are into uh into
video I like that it's codie we also
have a newsletter called
contrainthinking.com it's basically a
Weekly Newsletter all free about buying
businesses building businesses and how
to do them in ways that
your teachers never taught you but
probably should and it's free 99. so I
would go to one of those two things and
and maybe what I'd love to to hear from
all of you more than anything is we have
a mission of creating one million
financially free humans and a hundred
thousand small business owners and so
I'd like to put one of those on my
Tombstone so if you buy a business or if
you make money off of this I want to
hear about it if you do it out on
Twitter awesome if you do it on
Instagram awesome we keep this list of
everybody who's reached out to us who's
bought a business or who's increased
their revenue streams from the work that
we do in the world and we update it
every single week and so last week I
think we had like 86 million dollars in
profit from humans who said I'm gonna
bet on me and also you know the man
and I'm I'm into that awesome ladies and
gentlemen Cody Sanchez
[Applause]